in this video
we'll have a look at the four elements
of timing and direction
these are the four ways
the two circles can move together the
four basic ways
this structure is the foundation of
poi spinning and you'll find that it
applies to
any prop that has circles any movements
that use circles
even if you're if you don't use props if
you're just a movement practitioner and
you're just using your body
you can find that there's circles and
how the circles relate to each other
you can apply this this structure
so four times in directions
same time same direction the element of
earth
two circles both going the same
direction
at the same timing
earth the element of solidity
same time opposite direction
air
the classic poi move to butterfly uses
this
timing and direction
split time same direction
water the flowing element
split time opposite direction
fire
perhaps the more chaotic element or
sometimes described as that flickering
effect as it
crosses from side to side
four timings and directions four
elements
nice easy way to remember them
and at the same time it gives us
something richer
than the pure technicality of timing and
direction
because something more poetic something
that has a bit more soul
so depending on what you're doing
perhaps you want to look at it in true
different lenses you know there's a time
where we're looking at things purely
technically
we don't want anything extra we just
want to examine those
base pieces there's other times
where we want to look at things
with more feeling but something more
then perhaps the elements can be useful
either way i find it a much
easier way to talk about the timings of
directions
it's less of a mouthful one word instead
of two words
and for many people it's a little bit
easier
no right or wrong just cause and effect
try it out use what works for you
so let's have a look at
the four elements in terms of poi
we'll just work in the wheel plane to
begin with the poi spinning next to us
so we've got earth same time
same direction
if we split the timing we have water
split time same direction
earth water
if i change the direction of one of my
poi
same time opposite direction
up together down together
air same time
opposite direction
split time opposite direction fire
air fire
so if you want to go through these
examining earth
trying to get the timing as good as we
can
always striving to make things cleaner
can i make the plane sharper
can i make the movement smoother can i
release unnecessary tension through the
body
earth forwards
and backwards
water
again searching can i make it
cleaner can i reduce the tension
can i free my body
backwards water
split time
one forwards one backwards air
same time opposite direction
crossing at the bottom crossing at the
top
trying to keep the planes as clean as
possible
changing direction air
boat up together both down together
searching for any weaknesses searching
for where we can make improvements
releasing tension in the body
split time opposite direction fire
meeting at the front
meeting at the back
improving the planes improving the
timing
smoothening everything out
releasing the shoulders the elbows
the wrists relaxing the hands
letting the spine hang
feeling the weight in the feet
extending through the crown
changing direction fire
four timings and directions four
elements